if you think apple over charges for ram
you're absolutely right they charge
$3,000 to go from 32 gigabytes of ram to
192 so in this video i'll show you how
easy it is to replace it yourself and
get a hundred and ninety two gigs of ram
for only about $700 by using our links
down in the video description i'll also
prove that it works just as good as
apple's ram and we'll finish it off with
a guide on how much ram we recommend for
your specific use case first unplug the
power cable and anything connected to
your mac pro then twist the handle at
the top of the case and lift it off go
around to the back and push the unlock
switches to release the RAM covers then
pull them off to remove the factory Ram
push the tabs at each end of the RAM
sticks then carefully pull them straight
out you'll notice that there is a notch
on the RAM connector that's offset
towards one side of the stick before you
put in your new RAM grab the RAM cover
and take a look on the inside you'll see
a diagram that shows you which slot to
put your RAM for each configuration if
you've got six Ram sticks like most
people will you'll be placing them into
slots 1 3 5 8 10 and 12 now grab one of
your new Ram sticks and make sure that
the same notch matches up to the notch
on the Mac Pro's motherboard then
carefully push the RAM stick in you'll
hear a satisfying click when it's seated
and the tabs on each side will lock into
place once all your RAM is in put the
covers back on as well as the case and
you're done as you can see the RAM shows
up perfectly in the configurator
and runs at the full 29 33 megahertz
speed the Apple advertises now let's get
into our ram recommendation guide keep
in mind that we'll have links to those
RAM kits down in the description since
you're buying an expensive professional
Mac Pro we think that 96 gigs for 450
dollars is the perfect amount of RAM for
doing music production photo editing
compressed 4k video editing and most
other professional productivity
applications for those doing specific
tasks such as high resolution raw video
editing virtual machines really high-end
3d design or specific apps that can
utilize a lot of RAM we think a hundred
and ninety-two gigabytes for 700
$17 is a really good amount that
shouldn't limit the majority of
professionals and that's actually what
we bought for our Mac Pro now for those
that want to go all out three hundred
and eighty four gigabytes for fourteen
thirty four is honestly the most we'd
recommend even if you get the twenty
eight core CPU in fact Apple only used
up to three hundred eighty four gigs for
all the tests that they ran and showed
off on the Mac Pro product page proving
that even Apple thinks that's enough RAM
we've got links to those great deals on
all those RAM configurations that we
recommended down in the description just
make sure to order and use six sticks if
you want your RAM to run at full six
channel speed or use twelve thirty two
gigabytes sticks for that massive three
hundred eighty four gigabyte
configuration and if you're worried
about those links pointing to the right
RAM Apple actually provides a support
page with all the required RAM specs
they recommend so you can double check
our RAM links to verify that they match
up to Apple specs if you're wondering
what else is upgradeable on the Mac Pro
or if you want to see how loud the Mac
Pro gets under full load check out those
videos right over there and click that
circle above to subscribe for more Mac
Pro content coming very soon thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]